Hi how are you doing I come to tell you about my experience at the
universitat overter in Catalonia last year I did a master's degree in
finance and public health at stanley which is a uni which is distance
learning when I enrolled I was recommended not to enroll eh of the 60
credits that although it was a master's degree of 60 credits recommended
to do it in 2 years if eh I was working I wanted to get it in one um
because I needed it for the merits of the bag then well eh I enrolled of
everything em to do it in a year yes it is true that although in this
master there were no exams was all continuous evaluation
the papers that are sent to you are
I mean they are not jobs that I know you do in one afternoon,
you deliver them and that's it,
they are not hard jobs and they need dedication that they need to read a lot,
look for scientific methodological sources that are reliable,
etcetera,
pros of this university that you organize as you want,
they tell you the dates in which you have to deliver the
work in all subjects and you already organize yourself.
and in the cons in the cons especially the lack of accompaniment because the
teachers really do not give classes the teachers give you some instructions
that you have to follow to deliver the work you have the forum where you can
ask some questions but there are no classes then it is a little I stew it I
eat it and you also have to write down the dates because really in my case the
accompaniment was null even my tutor to remind us when we had to deliver
things as he forgot I think the vast majority of the time I would tell you 3
days after the date of delivery of the work and I hope why you let me know now
if 3 days ago I finished the delivery date I did not
do the tgm I do not do it in the tfm
the first time I enrolled I had no luck with my tutor,
she didn't check me at all,
she didn't talk to me,
she didn't answer my emails,
so I asked for a change of tutor,
but the uoc told me that they were very sorry,
that if I had learned that tutor and that I had to clarify with her,
the point is that I had to go to a second teacher,
which I didn't finish.
the master's degree in a year that I wanted but well I finished it in the
first four months of the following year and I was lucky with my tutor
because she was correcting me and answered my emails and it was my third
tfm I was not going to do this again so a tfg 2 tfm this was the third
one because the tutor skated there but well in general I have to say very well.